i recently started doing my research on
robin williams and he had some of like
the wildest pieces like he would have
like archive vape pieces and all type of
[ __ ] and i didn't even know that was
what robin williams was on he wearing
product shirts and all type
[Music]
what's up gq i'm brent fayash and these
are my essentials
[Music]
this month right here garnier fructis
makes another one that's pretty decent
but with this one either or
jamaican castor oil works too
but you know everybody's requirements on
scalp hygiene is different but if you
don't want to be flaky out here i
suggest you use something typically if i
just get my braid out something like
that take the braids out wash it put
your oil on there
i'll be straight smell good i never been
in morocco i know they got some good oil
[Music]
these nike cortez i got like a couple
cribs and i got a pair of these in every
single closet i didn't even realize it's
one of my favorite shoes until i really
sat and thought about how many pairs of
these i don't ran through it's these and
the chuck taylor's pretty much just like
some real la [ __ ] i like them when they
dusty too i like them when they age
going
you could wear these with slacks jeans
what i'm telling you you can wear these
[ __ ] with a suit you can wear
them with cargos you can wear them with
don't make matter remember whatever and
then sometimes you want to get on your
real la [ __ ] with a full dicky suit come
on [ __ ] cortez on them proper you can
wear them in any city it's going to be
appropriate it's a nice busted pair of
nike quartet
this had to at least be my like
12 13 pair like i got to be cozy like
when i'm getting dressed i can't just be
getting dressed to get some [ __ ] to look
cool that ain't really my style i got to
be comfortable with [ __ ]
these ironically are not the most
comfortable shoe though these are not
the most comfortable shoe at all you
walk on these [ __ ] for a
certain amount of time your feet gonna
hurt but it don't matter i like them new
balance is always gonna be the most
comfortable shoe they comfy as [ __ ]
but yeah this is my favorite stuff
playing cards typically people come out
of crib you got to have something out
you know i mean what you playing like by
some spades or you playing some
[ __ ] uh gym rummy whatever go
fish people come by the crib though they
got to play something get the drinks
going play the cards and [ __ ]
i'm bad at shuffling i'm bad as [ __ ] to
shuffle bro usually do all that [ __ ]
i'll be shopping like this i'll [ __ ]
around take them out and do like that
i'm the worst chef like ever i'll be
[ __ ] with the uno too i need some
little cards that's what i need to do i
never been big on video games nah that's
never really been my thing coming up my
mother really wasn't having it she
wasn't letting us play video games like
that she said it was gonna write your
brain or something so i used to put up
on the homies and finally got into
playing video games and they'd be
playing so long that i was some [ __ ] at
everything i played so they come out of
the house we playing this [ __ ] we're not
playing today
the skin condoms i was a magnum guy for
a little bit but i'mma be honest with
you like i really stopped [ __ ] with
the magnums because a lot of women have
like latex allergies and [ __ ] like that
so the skin condoms like trust me and i
don't got no kids so trust me feeding my
[ __ ] is proper
you don't even feel them when they are
no matter that
this is my journal my notebook i write
songs draw pictures sometimes i might go
to like a hotel and i like drawing over
draw pictures and [ __ ] like that like
that type of stuff
i was in atlanta at the fourth season so
i looked out the window to start a
drawing doodle in the buildings and [ __ ]
random [ __ ] for real my attention span
not really what it used to be i used to
be able to like sit and draw for hours
but now like my attention span don't
allow me to sit too long so the best i
really get is like some little postcard
doodles and [ __ ] like that i used to be
in this [ __ ] all the time but
now it's like i just kind of take [ __ ]
from other places and put it in it i
can't travel with this [ __ ]
because i lose it so i keep this [ __ ]
like tight
that's pretty much my mobile journal
i got like four or five of these
[ __ ] i think this one was like
the 11 some [ __ ] like that when this one
came out i got me like four or five of
these because you know i just be losing
phones all the time and [ __ ] so yeah i
just stick to this one don't keep
updating the new iphone every time i
give you a new one that's the layman
[ __ ] every time i get a new iphone come
out when you get the new iphone just
right now you found the one that you
[ __ ] with that you rock with and you
just hold on to that one
[ __ ] somebody just invited me to go
swimming
hey
this is autumn wanna come swim i don't
know who autumn is i don't
i don't know what that is
i don't know
probably not i don't like voice notes in
the text that should be blowing me i
hate that [ __ ] even when people send
them i don't want to listen to that like
let me just read it and then sometimes
depending on if it's a long voice note
i'll forget that it's a voice note and
i'll be trying to talk back
and no one's over there i don't like it
i'd rather text but i do like leaving
voice notes like when i'm working on
music like if i catch a melody and i'm
in the studio i'll hum in their room and
then play it back like yeah that's the
one right there and go and cut it
i usually don't like giving my scents
away but i got like a whole bunch of
them so i figured you know what i'll let
y'all get this one that's what i'm doing
but this is the background it's a good
one the roots 540 this is pretty good
it smells sweet i don't like scents that
smell too like um
too natural too like outside or too like
too alcoholy and [ __ ] i don't like that
i like it
smells sweet i won't smell like candy
when i walk around [ __ ]
take it
light on your mouth again
like that right there take it
and put it
your little spots yeah the little spots
that really hold a sense on your wrist
sometimes like below your belly button
[ __ ] like that i almost always find out
about like sense through women i'm like
man you smell good as [ __ ] take it
like
if i'm going to something real fancy
i'll probably take this like maybe mix
it with my gel and then mix that with
like a calvin klein it's
got to smell good man maybe oh my god
you smell so good what is that i'll just
be like it's just me just me baby
[Music]
the burberry trench is another essential
item for me it's another one of the
pieces you can pretty much just wear
with like anything i like things that
don't go out of style man it's something
about a trench that's just like some
classic like businessman [ __ ] i feel
proper when i wear a trench coat keep
you warm and got pockets and [ __ ] so i
can keep all type of [ __ ] in there so if
you got like cash or you got weed
whatever pockets is deep classic
burberry trench you got the burberry
print
i got black one green one i got a lot of
these but with this particular color
you're giving hugs and [ __ ] like that
then you'll [ __ ] run and get makeup
all over your [ __ ]
but take it to the drive finish you're
good to go certain things i keep in
every closet like my la closet is
different than my new york closet these
particular pieces like with a burberry
trench or like cortez things like that i
have them in every single closet type
[ __ ]
kanye karel i recently started like
doing my research on robin williams and
he had some of like the wildest pieces
like he would have like archive pieces
and all type of [ __ ] and i didn't even
know like that was what robin williams
was going to be wearing wild prada
shirts and all type of [ __ ] yeah robin
williams is crazy with it i like that
like retired actor like stila
like not really caring for real but just
put together that's really what i go by
some classic gentleman [ __ ] right
whether or not you smoke you like
candles whatever the [ __ ] i feel like
everybody needs a lighter on them every
man needs a lighter on him there's some
[ __ ] like i don't even care if you
strengthen the wilderness you got to
start a fire oh [ __ ] what i'm gonna do
got a light on you good you see shoddy
she's struggling to smoke i can't find
my ladder you gotta pull up like that
i got you like you like that for you
type [ __ ] you even got to smoke like
candles whatever this necessity right
there it's a classic big light i like
the black ones
they said the white ones is bad luck if
you got like just a plain white lighter
but i keep them [ __ ] too okay i'm not
superstitious at all
i'll step on cracks and split poles and
[ __ ] i don't care i'm too blessed to
have bad luck
i actually don't like bluetooth
headphones to be honest with you but
applejam made it so [ __ ] difficult so
you can't charge your phone while you
listen to music unless you got a pair of
these [ __ ] so the airpods i use
bose headphones i really like them big
studio headphones those are my favorite
shits because i didn't like never lost
them these fall out my ears all the
[ __ ] time if i'm on the plane they
almost always end up under the chair and
somebody gotta be like you lost your
airpod
right now i was listening to poc on the
way over here i was listening all eyes
on me i like street [ __ ] if i'm
listening to new [ __ ] it's probably just
street music trey imani
um junie
amber olivier
yeah that's what i'll be on yeah i came
up on music music was everything i need
to listen to music at all times
i was going through a face for a little
bit where i didn't listen to music for a
while and i was wondering why i was like
in a bad head space and i didn't even
realize i hadn't listened to music in a
while i could go from nirvana to stevie
wonder to [ __ ] um radiohead
from [ __ ]
gunu to muffet like it don't i listen to
whatever
i'm a big uh lyrics person i tend to
listen for the words like as well as
production too but i'm big on lyrics i
would love to do a duo with whitney
houston she probably bited me on that
[ __ ] but yeah i don't care that
should be hard it'd be an honor for her
to kill me on the track
[Music]
so these are my essentials thanks for
watching